the road to Tripoli this is general
hectares self-start militia it's
substantial and it's moving west in a
bid to take the capital general after
who's now on the move controls the south
and the east of the country he set his
sights on the Libyan capital the United
Nations backed government based in
Tripoli is supported by a range of
militias in order to defend the city
militias that support the UN backed
government are deploying their own
troops to fend off general haft arse
offensive but after who ordered his
troops to take the capital on Thursday
is determined heroes the time has come
it is time to advance as you have always
done with a firm step towards Tripoli
and to enter it peacefully for Libyans
this is another escalation in a long and
gritty power struggle conflict has
rumbled on since the fall of Muammar
Gaddafi in 2011 with militias vying for
power and control of Libya's oil the
international community is worried the
head of the United Nations Antonio
Guterres was in Tripoli this week
speaking with both general CAFTA and the
UN backed governments just before
leaving Libya on Friday evening he
talked of hope I still hope it would be
possible to avoid a bloody confrontation
in and around Tripoli and the United
Nations remain available to facilitate
any political solution able to unify the
Libyan institutions
and whatever happens the UN will remain
committed and I will remain committed to
support the Libyan people but hope seems
to be running out near the capital half
task forces are clashing with the
militias that support the un-backed
government the situation is uncertain
but half tarz advance is unlikely to
bring peace the risk is renewed civil
war for more on the situation in Libya
were joined by Mona hefney of DWS Arabic
service Mona thanks so much for joining
us thank you
militia forces commanded by Khalifa
Haftar they're advancing on the capital
the un-backed government in Tripoli has
sent out its militias in an attempt to
stop them tell us how serious is the
situation it is quite serious right now
because as we have seen fighting has
been ongoing yesterday night around the
former international airport of Tripoli
also after the meeting of UN General
Guterres with with hafter at the UN
envoy to Libya Hassan Salameh said that
half-turn made it obvious that he had no
interest in halting the campaign and it
is quite obvious that after is
determined to take over the capital so
it is quite serious
tell us more about Khalifa Haftar what
exactly is he trying to achieve he is a
quite powerful man he has quite a rich
history he has helped Gaddafi to
overthrow the former king of Libya then
afterwards while he was in Chad he was
captured for almost twenty years
afterwards he moved to exile in the US
and worked for the CIA there and he
helped he helped for the fall of Gaddafi
afterwards in 2011
now his most important aim is to take
over the capital of course because the
one who takes over the capital is the
one in power basically if he succeeds
what could happen if the UN bad
government failed it is quite unclear
what we have what will happen right now
because we could have one scenario which
is quite similar to the Egyptian
scenario with cracking down the Muslim
Brotherhood which is centered in the
capital right now but the thing is that
other countries around Libya would
might be also endangered because he has
threatened last year Algeria - to start
a war and he has said that he will move
up to Tripoli and then afterwards he
might move to Algeria which which might
mean that there will be also turbulence
around Libya
what could the international community
do to stop this situation from
escalating further I think the
international community can't do very
much because first the international
community all only condemns things by
words it does not really interfere
although there are also double standards
like in the like the Emirates who stated
that it is against this intervention but
on the other hand the smooth but on the
other hand it supports after so we don't
really know what's happening right now
but I think in the end it will not much
will happen because half there is a man
not a man of words he's a man who talks
with weapons and who is determined to
reach his goal we're in a hefney thank
you so much for your analysis thank you